tenir et continuer à résister près de
baccout ces militaires Ukrainiens font
tout pour repousser les forces russes
l'ennemius s'utilise avant tout
l'infanterie ils n'ont pas la même
quantité de véhicule blindés qu'avant
donc
ils ont beaucoup d'infanterie et c'est
la cible principale de notre système de
lancement multiroquette Moscou
revendique de nouvelles avancées dans la
région et la pression se fait de plus en
plus forte notamment après la chute de
soledar près de makmouth que les forces
ukrainiennes ont dû céder après des
semaines de combat meurtriers
dans le village de yampil libérée en
septembre les habitants craignent une
nouvelle occupation russe
si les Russes viennent nous n'avons
nulle part où aller
nous nul part ou fuir la maison de
Victoria a été endommagée par les
bombardements de l'été dernier elle n'a
pas pu la réparer avant l'hiver faute
d'argent
cet hiver on s'en sortira d'une manière
ou d'une autre mais comment sera l'hiver
prochain je ne peux même pas imaginer je
n'ai ni travail ni argent
les autorités ukrainiennes redoutent une
grande offensive de Moscou dans les
prochaines semaines objectif pour les
Russes tentez de prendre backmouth pour
ouvrir la voie un assaut vers
cramatorzek principal ville du Dombas
encore administré parquet